When I reached Eric Pahls three weeks ago, he was on the road. In fact, it was his second day on the road, headed from Kansas, where he's from, to Washington, DC.
三周前我联系到埃里克·帕尔斯（Eric Pahls）时，他正在路上。事实上，这已是他启程的第二天，他正从家乡堪萨斯州前往华盛顿特区。
I am in the mountains of southwest Pennsylvania-- or hills-- right now, so I hope I don't lose you.
我现在身处宾夕法尼亚州西南部的山区——或者说是丘陵地带——所以希望信号不会中断。
I'd say that part of the drive is so incredible because suddenly you really are not in the Midwest.
我觉得这段车程非常不可思议，因为突然之间，你真的就不再处于中西部了。
Right. The houses get older and the land gets a little more diverse than it was.
没错。房子变老了，地形也比之前更多样化。
Yeah. There's hills suddenly.
是啊。突然就出现了丘陵。
Yeah. Right. Not flat, I guess, in other words.
对。换句话说，不再平坦了。
Yeah. And describe the scene. Explain who's with each other right there in the truck.
没错。描述一下现场吧。解释一下卡车里现在都有谁。
Yeah, we are in a GMC pickup with a U-Haul trailer on the back of it. My dad's driving. My younger brother's in here, as well.
好的，我们开着一辆GMC皮卡，后面拖着一辆U-Haul挂车。我爸爸在开车。我弟弟也在车里。
And explain why you're going to DC.
再解释一下你为什么要回华盛顿特区。
I'm going because I am the press secretary for an incoming congressman.
我去是因为我是一位新任国会议员的新闻秘书。
Not just a press secretary, the 22-year-old press secretary, fresh out of college, for a first-time congressman who's never held elective office himself, Republican Roger Marshall of Kansas' first district. Eric got the job since Roger Marshall was a long-shot candidate, a doctor. And Eric was his press secretary for the campaign. Eric's previous Washington experience? Intern. In a way, the two of them are like Donald Trump and many of his appointees. They're newbies to politics now thrown into the biggest political swamp in the country.
不仅是一位新闻秘书，还是那位22岁、刚走出校门，为一位从未担任过民选公职的首次当选国会议员——堪萨斯州第一选区的共和党人罗杰·马歇尔（Roger Marshall）工作的新闻秘书。埃里克之所以得到这份工作，是因为罗杰·马歇尔当时只是一位不被看好的候选人，一名医生。埃里克则是他竞选团队的新闻秘书。埃里克之前的华盛顿经验？实习生。在某种程度上，他们俩就像唐纳德·特朗普及其许多任命官员一样。他们都是政治新手，现在被扔进了全国最大的政治泥潭中。
On the road, Eric's been getting advice from his dad on how to stick to a personal budget. He's not making that much money in his new job. And he's been trying to get his father and his brother to listen to some very old music-- Kris Kristofferson; The Eagles; Fleetwood Mac; oh, and Elvis.
在路上，埃里克一直听取父亲关于如何坚持个人预算的建议。他在新工作中挣得并不多。他一直试图让父亲和弟弟听一些非常老派的音乐——克里斯·克里斯托佛森（Kris Kristofferson）、老鹰乐队（The Eagles）、佛利伍麦克合唱团（Fleetwood Mac），哦，还有猫王。
And I know that becomes a little more cliche young Republican, but Crosby, Stills, and Nash--
我知道这听起来有点像年轻共和党人的老套路，但是克罗斯比、斯蒂尔斯与纳什合唱团（Crosby, Stills, and Nash）——
Dude, that's Democrats' music.
老兄，那是民主党人的音乐。
That's right. Yeah, they were like '68, outside-the-convention music.
说得对。是的，他们那是68年代表大会外的音乐。
Back in the U-Haul, there's furniture that he just bought from Ikea for his new tiny studio apartment; a recliner from home that he brought, despite his mom's objections; and ties-- lots of ties.
在U-Haul后面，装满了家具，是他刚为自己那间小小的单间公寓从宜家买的；还有一个他从家里带来的躺椅，尽管他妈妈反对；还有领带——很多很多的领带。
I didn't realize I had that many ties till I went to pack. I would say probably 30 to 40 ties.
我打包的时候才发现自己有那么多领带。我想大概有30到40条吧。
Oh, wow. You own more than I do.
哇。你拥有的比我还多。
Well, last Christmas I asked to be a member of the Tie of the Month club.
嗯，去年圣诞节我申请成为了“月度领带俱乐部”的一员。
Now, I'm no expert on being a press secretary, but from seeing them on TV, it just seems like you could get by with like four ties-- blue, red, blue stripe, red stripe.
现在，我虽不是新闻秘书方面的专家，但从电视上看，我觉得四条领带就足够应付了——蓝色、红色、蓝条纹、红条纹。
Right. I get really self-conscious about wearing the same tie like more than once in a couple weeks. I also just really like ties.
对。我真的很在意在几周内戴同一条领带。而且我也真的非常喜欢领带。
Eric is very aware that's he's going to be working on Capitol Hill during a historic moment in our country, with a president who's all about disruptive change and a Republican Congress that's out to prove what it can accomplish.
埃里克非常清楚，他将要在我国历史性的时刻在国会山工作，面对一位热衷于破坏性变革的总统，以及一个急于证明其成就的共和党国会。
Not that Eric agrees with the new president on every issue. He doesn't want to build a wall and he comes from a big agricultural congressional district, so he likes our current trade deals. Hes likes the TPP. But he's an idealistic young conservative, the kind of Republican fanboy who was thrilled when he met Bob Dole and John McCain and Jerry Moran. And if you're asking yourself, who's Jerry Moran? Well, then that is exactly my point. He's excited to see his team poised for big things.
并不是说埃里克在所有议题上都同意这位新总统的观点。他不想修墙，而且他来自一个大型农业国会选区，所以他喜欢我们现有的贸易协定。他喜欢跨太平洋伙伴关系协定（TPP）。但他是一个理想主义的年轻保守派，属于那种见到鲍勃·多尔（Bob Dole）、约翰·麦凯恩（John McCain）和杰里·莫兰（Jerry Moran）就会激动的共和党小迷弟。如果你问自己，杰里·莫兰是谁？那么，这正是我的观点。他很高兴看到他的团队准备大干一场。
The Republicans, for all my lifetime, have been fighting for an opportunity such as this. And it obviously did not come in the package that most of us thought it would come in, but it's here. And here's our big audition and we best not screw it up or it's going to be another lifetime, if we even get another chance.
共和党人，在我这一生中，一直在争取这样的机会。它显然不是以我们大多数人预想的方式到来的，但它确实到了。这是我们的大考，我们最好不要搞砸，否则即便还有下一次机会，也要再等上一辈子。
Well, today on our program, it's inauguration weekend. And after this insanely divisive and bitter election, we seem to be heading into these next four years with some people super stoked for what's about to happen and others horrified and frightened. Today's program reflects that. We're going to hear from both groups. And given the mutual animosity between the two sides, we have worked extra hard to find Republicans to put on the air who Democrats would find interesting to listen to and maybe even kind of like, and to find Democrats who Republicans would find interesting to listen to and maybe even like. You can be the judge of how well we did.
今天在我们的节目中，是总统就职周末。在经历了这场极其分裂且痛苦的选举后，我们似乎正迈入接下来的四年，有些人对即将发生的事情兴奋不已，而另一些人则感到惊恐和害怕。今天的节目反映了这一点。我们将听到两方的声音。鉴于双方的相互敌意，我们付出了额外努力，寻找那些民主党人会觉得听起来很有趣、甚至可能有点喜欢的共和党人上节目，并寻找那些共和党人会觉得听起来很有趣、甚至可能喜欢的民主党人。你们可以评判我们做得如何。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, Mean Come True.
第一幕，愿望成真（Mean Come True）。
Thursday night in the same room where the annual White House Correspondents' dinner is held was the DeploraBall. The crowd was in a mix of inaugural formal wear-- gowns, heels, minks-- plus tons of young people in jeans and T-shirts-- red "Make America Great" hats everywhere, of course. It's not unusual for people at any inaugural ball to congratulate themselves for electing the president. These balls are for donors and fundraisers and organizers, after all.
周四晚上，在举办年度白宫记者晚宴的同一个厅里，举行了“令人痛惜者舞会”（DeploraBall）。人群穿着各式各样的就职典礼正装——礼服、高跟鞋、貂皮大衣——此外还有许多穿着牛仔裤和T恤的年轻人——当然，到处都是红色的“让美国再次伟大”帽子。在任何就职舞会上，人们为选出总统而自我祝贺并不罕见。毕竟，这些舞会是为捐赠者、筹款人和组织者举办的。
At the DeploraBall, people made the case for themselves this way. Jay Boone and Conor O'Hagan explain to our producer Zoe Chace, using a curse word, by the way, that we did not beep here in the podcast. The crowd at this ball--
在“令人痛惜者舞会”上，人们这样为自己辩护。杰伊·布恩（Jay Boone）和康纳·奥哈根（Conor O'Hagan）向我们的制作人佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）解释道，顺便说一句，他们用了一个脏话，我们在播客中没有消音。舞会上的这群人——
We did it. We memed him into the presidency.
我们做到了。我们通过表情包（meme）把他送上了总统宝座。
You memed him?
你们发表情包？
We memed him into power. We shit-posted our way into the future.
我们用表情包把他送进了权力中心。我们靠发布垃圾信息走向了未来。
It's true. This is true.
是真的。这是真的。
This is true because we directed the culture.
这是真的，因为我们引导了文化。
Directed the culture, he said, through social media-- making snarky memes for Twitter and Facebook, creating a climate, disseminating a rolling, trolling message over months and months. Zoe explains what they're talking about and how they all ended up in this room.
引导文化，他说，通过社交媒体——为推特和脸书制作讽刺性的表情包，制造一种氛围，在几个月的时间里散布一种滚动式的嘲弄信息。佐伊解释了他们所谈论的内容，以及他们是如何最终聚在这个房间里的。
This is a place where being called a troll is a compliment. And the best trollers from Twitter are the celebrity guests. Kat Niedermair explains the original concept for the ball like this.
这是一个被称为“喷子”（troll）被视为赞美的地方。推特上最棒的“喷子”是这里的明星嘉宾。凯特·尼德迈尔（Kat Niedermair）这样解释这个舞会的原始概念。
A meeting of the trolls. A troll con. It would be a gathering of some of the most triggering personalities. There would be a video playing or projected of all of the top memes of the election.
喷子们的聚会。一场喷子大会。这将是一些最容易引发争议的人物的集会。还会播放或投影出选举中所有最热门表情包的视频。
Kat is a small, twitchy, 22-year-old girl-- big eyes, enormous glasses, stringy blonde hair, online marketer/anarchist/libertarian/punk kid. She spends a lot of time on Twitter. Everyone at this ball pretty much got to know each other online, in Twitter chat rooms, on Reddit threads like "The Donald," online forums like 4Chan and 8Chan. There was much to discuss and analyze and joke about in these corners of the internet during this election. Like when those Podesta WikiLeaks came out, thousands of emails to and from Hillary Clinton's campaign chairman, this was the army that weaponized that information for political warfare. They wanted to get that information out.
凯特是一个个子娇小、有些抽动症的22岁女孩——大眼睛、大眼镜、干枯的金色头发，网上营销人员/无政府主义者/自由意志主义者/朋克小孩。她在推特上花了很多时间。舞会上的每个人基本上都是在网上认识的，在推特聊天室、红迪网（Reddit）的“The Donald”板块，以及4Chan和8Chan等在线论坛上。在这次选举期间，互联网的这些角落里有很多可以讨论、分析和调侃的话题。比如当波德斯塔（Podesta）的“维基解密”（WikiLeaks）曝光时，成千上万封希拉里·克林顿竞选主席的邮件外泄，这就是那支将这些信息武器化进行政治战争的军队。他们想要把这些信息传播出去。
I wasn't one of those people who was reading every WikiLeaks, but a lot of my friends were. I knew a batch would drop. Someone would download them. Many people would download them. Many people would read through them. And then there was a bit of an industry created. You've got a few different types of people that you'll find in the Twittersphere. There are the researchers. There are the compilers. And then there's the meme magicians.
我不是那种阅读每一份“维基解密”文件的人，但我很多朋友是。我知道会有一批文件泄露。有人会下载它们。许多人会下载它们。许多人会通读它们。然后就形成了一个小的产业。你在推特圈里会发现几种不同类型的人。有研究人员。有汇总人员。还有表情包魔术师。
The meme magicians?
表情包魔术师？
Yes. The meme magicians. They are the ones who are able to translate what the people who are spending 18 hours a day reading through the emails.
是的。表情包魔术师。他们是那些能够将那些每天花18小时阅读邮件的人所发现的内容转化出来的人。
Here's how it works. This is an email from the chairman of Hillary's campaign to other people on the team about potential vice presidential picks.
运作方式是这样的。这是一封希拉里竞选主席发给团队其他成员关于潜在副总统人选的邮件。
So this is from Podesta from March the 17th, 2016. "Let me know if there are people you would like to see added or removed before we begin the process. I have organized names in rough food groups." And from there, the food groups begin. The first group is Javier Becerra, Julian Castro, Eric Garcetti, Tom Perez, Ken Salazar.
这是波德斯塔2016年3月17日的邮件。“在我们开始这个过程之前，让我知道你们想添加或移除的人。我已经按大致的类别组织好了名字。”从那里开始，分类就开始了。第一组是哈维尔·贝塞拉（Javier Becerra）、朱利安·卡斯特罗（Julian Castro）、埃里克·加塞蒂（Eric Garcetti）、汤姆·佩雷斯（Tom Perez）、肯·萨拉查（Ken Salazar）。
It's a group of Hispanic people. Then it's a group of women, mostly white women. There's a group of black people, a group of rich people.
这是一组西班牙裔人。然后是一组女性，主要是白人女性。有一组黑人，一组富人。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Yeah.
是啊。
And Bernie Sanders.
还有伯尼·桑德斯（Bernie Sanders）。
还有伯尼·桑德斯。
One of the meme magicians, this guy Triggerbait, turned that into a meme. Simple, just a picture of the food pyramid with little emojis of black people at the base, Hispanic people and women right above, rich people at the top. He included a link to the original email. Kat's job was to collect stuff like this and spread it around. Like before a presidential debate, she'd put the word out.
其中一位表情包魔术师，这个叫Triggerbait的家伙，把它变成了一个表情包。很简单，就是一张金字塔图，底部是黑人的小表情符号，上面是西班牙裔人和女性，顶端是富人。他附上了原始邮件的链接。凯特的工作就是收集这类东西并传播出去。就像在总统辩论之前，她会发出消息。
Because we need memes. Need more memes.
因为我们需要表情包。需要更多的表情包。
The great thing about the Podesta emails in particular, she says, is they got everyone working together. A bunch of the Twitter trolls swarmed together on the same quest.
她说，波德斯塔邮件最棒的地方在于，它让每个人都团结在一起。一大群推特喷子聚集在一起执行同一个任务。
That's kind of the funny thing about trolls. If they don't have a thing to do, then they're going to be trolling either way. But if they've got a mission with a clear focus, it meant that the trolls were trolling, but they were all trolling in the same direction, sort of.
这正是喷子有趣的地方。如果他们没正事做，他们无论如何都会去喷。但如果他们有一个目标明确的任务，那就意味着喷子们虽然在喷，但他们基本上都在朝着同一个方向喷。
Right. Around these emails.
没错。围绕这些邮件。
Yeah.
是啊。
And when Trump's campaign was at its lowest point, after the Access Hollywood tape came out and Republican leaders were abandoning him, the deplorables swooped in to the rescue. Some of the most popular trolls on Twitter came up with this MAGA3X hashtag. That's Make America Great Again three times. Do three Trump things every day. Hold pro-Trump flash mobs. Get three Trump supporters to the polls. Retweet three Trump-related memes.
当特朗普的竞选处于最低谷时，在《走进好莱坞》录像带曝光、共和党领袖们纷纷抛弃他之后，那些“令人痛惜者”出手相救。推特上最受欢迎的一些喷子想出了“MAGA3X”这个标签。意思是“让美国再次伟大”三次（Make America Great Again 3 times）。每天做三件特朗普相关的事。举办亲特朗普的快闪活动。带三个特朗普支持者去投票。转发三个特朗普相关的表情包。
This did reach a lot of people, including deplorable Wiggleman-- Phillip Wiglesworth offline. He's a vet living in Florida. He voted for Obama in 2008. He'd started this election as Trump-curious. He got caught up retweeting all these nutty memes and jokes till he became a hardcore Trump fan. Basically, he's the 3X in MAGA3X.
这确实触及了很多人，包括“令人痛惜的维格尔曼”（Deplorable Wiggleman）——线下名字叫菲利普·威格斯沃斯（Phillip Wiglesworth）。他是一位住在佛罗里达州的退伍军人。他在2008年投给了奥巴马。他开始这场选举时对特朗普持观望态度。他沉迷于转发所有这些疯狂的表情包和笑话，直到他成为了特朗普的铁粉。基本上，他就是MAGA3X里的那个“3X”。
There's a nice, really funny YouTube video. Let me find it in my favorites here really quick.
有一个很好、非常有趣的YouTube视频。让我快速在我的收藏夹里找一下。
This is one of his personal favorites.
这是他个人的最爱之一。
His YouTube name his SocialistMop. And he did a video on Hillary Clinton and James Comey. And he put James Comey's press conference to music with auto-tune.
他的YouTube名字叫SocialistMop。他做了一个关于希拉里·克林顿和詹姆斯·科米（James Comey）的视频。他给詹姆斯·科米的新闻发布会配上了电音（auto-tune）。
(AUTOTUNED) Good morning. I'm here to give you an update on the FBI's investigation of Secretary Clinton. What I'm gonna do is tell you what we're recommending, but first let me tell you what we found. 110 emails, 52 email chains have been determined to contain classified information--
（电音）早上好。我在这里向大家通报联邦调查局对克林顿国务卿调查的最新进展。我要做的是告诉大家我们的建议，但首先让我告诉你们我们发现了什么。110封邮件，52个邮件链被认定包含机密信息——
Deplorable Wiggleman came to the DeploraBall to commune with like-minded retweeters. He wasn't the type to comb through WikiLeaks himself. He just laughed at what came around. He'd started following some of the leaders of the MAGA3X team-- Mike Cernovich, Jack Posobiec-- over the summer. By September, he was fully in. He changed his name, took a movement name. His old Twitter handle was Harleytime1.
“令人痛惜的维格尔曼”来到“令人痛惜者舞会”，是为了与志同道合的转发者们交流。他不是那种自己去翻阅“维基解密”的人。他只是对传出来的东西感到好笑。他在夏天开始关注MAGA3X团队的一些领导者——迈克·切尔诺维奇（Mike Cernovich）、杰克·波索比克（Jack Posobiec）。到九月份，他完全入伙了。他改了名字，采用了运动名。他旧的推特账号是Harleytime1。
I made it Deplorable Wiggleman when Hillary called us deplorable. The Twitterverse grabbed hold of that moniker and we owned it. And I think that's why she lost.
当希拉里称我们为“令人痛惜的人”时，我把它改成了“令人痛惜的维格尔曼”。推特世界抓住了那个称呼，我们认领了它。我认为这就是她失败的原因。
Because she said the word "deplorable"?
因为她说出了“令人痛惜”这个词？
Mhm. I personally-- yeah. Yeah, definitely. She also called Bernie supporters, what? Basement dwellers? Oh, my goodness. Is she trying to lose votes? That's what it seems like.
嗯。我个人——是的。是的，绝对。她还把伯尼的支持者称为，什么？地下室居民？天哪。她是想输掉选票吗？看起来是这样。
On election night, he waited up till it was clear Trump had won.
选举之夜，他一直等到确定特朗普获胜。
I got out. I put my flag on my motorcycle, and I went and rode around town for a couple hours at 2, 3, 4 o'clock in the morning. Got myself some McDonald's for breakfast then came home and went to bed. To counter Michelle Obama, it was the first time in a long time that I felt hope for our country. Really felt hope for our country.
我出门了。我在摩托车上插上旗子，凌晨2点、3点、4点在镇上骑了几个小时。给自己买了麦当劳当早餐，然后回家睡觉。与米歇尔·奥巴马（Michelle Obama）的观点相反，这是我很久以来第一次感受到对我们国家的希望。真的感受到了对我们国家的希望。
I don't need to tell you that lots of people felt the opposite on election night-- despair, fear. Trump's America doesn't necessarily feel like a welcoming space for everybody. Deplorable Twitter does not, either. This pro-Trump corner of the internet can be super racist. It includes people who call themselves alt-right, or white nationalists.
我不用告诉你，许多人在选举之夜感受到了相反的东西——绝望、恐惧。特朗普的美国并不一定让人觉得对每个人都是一个受欢迎的空间。令人痛惜的推特空间也不是。这个亲特朗普的互联网角落可能非常种族主义。它包括那些自称“另类右翼”或白人民族主义者的人。
It seems like, in a way, some of the deplorable internet, the trolling internet, was creating a space to say racist stuff.
看起来，在某种程度上，一些令人痛惜的互联网、喷子互联网，正在创造一个说种族主义言论的空间。
So the more that it offends and the more that it triggers, the more they'll say it.
所以越是冒犯，越是引发争议，他们就越会说。
Kat says it doesn't mean they're actually haters. They're making a point. We go over this one guy's tweets, Baked Alaska. Big Twitter personality in this world. He does stuff like retweet white supremacist David Duke.
凯特说这并不意味着他们真的是仇恨者。他们是在表达观点。我们翻看一个家伙的推文，Baked Alaska。这个世界里的大推特名人。他做些转发白人至上主义者大卫·杜克（David Duke）之类的事情。
But he tweets out hateful things.
但他转发的是仇恨言论。
Are they really hateful?
它们真的那么令人仇恨吗？
"I can't wait till you're deported," "deport you." That is hateful.
“我等不及要让你被驱逐出境了”、“驱逐你”。那是仇恨。
Yeah, I guess. I think he's joking, though.
是啊，我想是吧。但我认为他是在开玩笑。
Yeah, but--
是的，但是——
I know, I know.
我知道，我知道。
You kind of like that stuff?
你有点喜欢那些东西？
Uh-- no. I mean, yeah. I don't know. I like trolling. I enjoy trolling because I think that things should be talked about. I think that trolling encourages that. But I don't know. I mean, I think that if you're saying that actually at somebody, then-- I mean, it depends on the context.
呃——不。我的意思是，是的。我不知道。我喜欢喷人。我喜欢喷人是因为我认为有些事情应该被谈论。我认为喷人鼓励了这一点。但我不知道。我的意思是，我认为如果你真的在对某人说这些话，那么——我的意思是，这取决于语境。
We go back and forth. I tell her, I don't get why you'd make hateful jokes like that. Ever. She says, it's making a bigger point about free speech and political correctness. I'm like, this is creating an environment where an actual guy came to DC and, at the end of his speech, called out, heil Trump.
我们反复争论。我告诉她，我不明白你为什么要开这种恶毒的玩笑。永远不该开。她说，这是为了表达关于言论自由和政治正确的更宏大的观点。我说，这创造了一种环境，一个真正的人来到华盛顿，在演讲结束时喊出了“希特勒万岁”（heil Trump）。
He was trolling.
他在喷人。
But why is that a joke?
但为什么那是个笑话？
Because you can't say it. Because it offends people. That's why it's a joke.
因为你不能说。因为它冒犯了人。这就是为什么它是笑话。
It offends people, but it also has consequences, right? Like when people said heil Hitler, there were these big consequences. They just don't care about the consequences?
它冒犯了人，但它也有后果，对吧？就像当人们说“希特勒万岁”时，会有严重的后果。他们只是不在乎后果吗？
Not really. But they also-- he said "hail Trump" because he thought it was funny, because it's like not really quite "heil," but it's like very close. I see a lot of the kids online are either LARPing-- Live-Action Role-Playing-- or just seeking to offend because they want a reaction.
并不是。但他们也——他说“希特勒万岁”是因为他觉得很有趣，因为它不太像“希特勒”（heil），但它非常接近。我在网上看到很多孩子要么是在进行真人角色扮演（LARPing），要么只是为了冒犯，因为他们想要得到反应。
I wonder if that's what Trump is doing, playing a role to get a reaction. Is Trump LARPing? Trolling? Is he saying what he actually believes? Kat thinks Trump's been trolling since the beginning.
我怀疑特朗普是不是也在做同样的事，扮演一个角色来得到反应。特朗普是在进行真人角色扮演吗？在喷人吗？他在说他真正相信的东西吗？凯特认为特朗普从一开始就在喷人。
He was completely trolling the Republican establishment.
他完全是在喷共和党建制派。
Little Marco, Lyin' Ted, inviting Bill Clinton's rape accuser to the presidential debate-- he offended his way to the top. Or as Kat puts it, Donald Trump trolled his way into becoming the President of the United States of America. That's why they like him. He's one of them. The greatest troll who's ever been.
“小马可”、“撒谎的泰德”，邀请比尔·克林顿的性侵指控者参加总统辩论——他靠冒犯一路登顶。或者正如凯特所说，唐纳德·特朗普一路喷成了美利坚合众国的总统。这就是为什么他们喜欢他。他就是他们中的一员。史上最伟大的喷子。
And the DeploraBall, Kat tells me, that's the place for the trolls of Twitter to celebrate the troll-in-chief.
凯特告诉我，“令人痛惜者舞会”就是推特喷子们庆祝那位“总喷子”的地方。
[CROWD CHEERING]
（人群欢呼）
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our show.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Two, Dreamers Get Real.
第二幕，梦想家认清现实（Dreamers Get Real）。
So President Trump has said from the beginning that he would get rid of DACA. DACA is short for Deferred Action for Childhood Arrivals. It's the executive action taken by President Obama for the DREAM Act kids who were brought to the United States when they were children. Under DACA, they got to register with the government, and, in exchange, they didn't get deported. Suddenly they could get work permits, which was a big deal. President Trump could end DACA immediately in his first week.
特朗普总统从一开始就说过他要废除“童年抵美暂缓遣返计划”（DACA）。DACA是“童年抵美暂缓遣返”的缩写。这是奥巴马总统为那些在童年时期被带到美国的“梦想者法案”（DREAM Act）孩子们所采取的行政行为。根据DACA，他们可以向政府登记，作为交换，他们不会被驱逐出境。突然间，他们可以获得工作许可证，这意义重大。特朗普总统可能在他上任的第一周就立即结束DACA。
But after the election, he seemed to backpedal a little on DACA and said in interviews that he would, quote, "work something out for DACA recipients." So since the election DACA recipients have not been sure what to think. Of course, they're worried. If DACA is rescinded, their names and addresses are in a government database. The government knows where to find them if it wants to end their protections and deport them.
但在选举之后，他在DACA问题上似乎有所回缩，并在采访中表示，他会引用他的话说，“为DACA接收者解决一些问题”。所以自选举以来，DACA接收者一直不确定该想些什么。当然，他们很担心。如果DACA被废除，他们的姓名和地址都在政府数据库里。如果政府想要结束对他们的保护并将他们驱逐出境，政府知道在哪里找到他们。
Reporter Seth Freed Wessler has been talking to several DACA kids since the election, and he's found some who were thinking about their options.
记者塞斯·弗里德·韦斯勒（Seth Freed Wessler）自选举以来一直在与几位DACA孩子交谈，他发现一些人正在考虑他们的选择。
A few weeks after the election, Kenia and her brother Henrri started planning a trip to El Salvador, where they were born. They haven't been back in 12 years. And at this point, they're total New York kids. She's 22 and studies film, and she looks like it. She wears black, has chunky glasses. Henrri's 21. He's a music major, plays classical guitar. Preppier than his sister.
选举后几周，肯尼亚（Kenia）和她弟弟亨利（Henrri）开始计划去他们出生的萨尔瓦多旅行。他们已经12年没回去了。目前看来，他们是彻头彻尾的纽约孩子。她22岁，学电影，长相就是那种风格。她穿黑色衣服，戴着粗框眼镜。亨利21岁。他是音乐专业，弹古典吉他。比他姐姐更像预科生。
Kenya says that the threat that Donald Trump could just rescind DACA, that she might have to go back to being totally undocumented, or even be deported, it made her wonder.
肯尼亚说，特朗普可能会废除DACA的威胁，她可能不得不回到完全无证的状态，甚至被驱逐出境，这让她产生了一些想法。
I'm thinking, could I make my home somewhere else? Can El Salvador become home? If I migrated to a country and thought of it as my home before, can I do that again? Can I just go somewhere else?
我在想，我能去其他地方安家吗？萨尔瓦多能成为家吗？如果我曾移民到一个国家并把它当作过我的家，我能再次这样做吗？我能去别的地方吗？
She and her brother wanted to go back to El Salvador, for a visit, just to see what it would be like just in case they had to go back someday.
她和她弟弟想回萨尔瓦多参观，只是为了看看万一哪天不得不回去会是什么样子。
That's the only thing I really have control over right now. I don't have control over Trump becoming president. I don't have control about the decisions he's going to take. But I do have control in seeing my family right now.
这是我现在唯一能控制的事情。我无法控制特朗普成为总统。我无法控制他将要做的决定。但我现在能控制去见我的家人。
Most of her family is still in El Salvador. In November, their grandfather had a stroke. It seemed like he could die soon. He'd pretty much raised them before they left for America. Kenia and Henrri really wanted to see him. And they found out that people with DACA can apply for this special permission to leave the US and come back in, but you need a really good reason to leave, like a family emergency, which they now had with their grandfather. Here's Henrri.
她的大部分家人还在萨尔瓦多。十一月，他们的祖父中风了。看起来他可能很快就会去世。在他们离开去美国之前，基本是他把他们带大的。肯尼亚和亨利真的很想见他。他们发现DACA身份的人可以申请这种特殊许可离开美国再回来，但你需要一个很好的离开理由，比如家庭紧急情况，而他们现在就遇到了祖父的问题。这是亨利。
Knowing that he's sick right now and who knows how long he has does scare me. I want to see him as soon as possible. I'm honestly scared for his health.
知道他现在病得很重，不知道还能撑多久，这确实让我害怕。我想尽快见到他。老实说，我很担心他的健康。
In the weeks after the election, a lot more DACA recipients applied to travel abroad than usual-- four times as many according to a couple of lawyers I talked to.
选举后的几周内，申请出国旅行的DACA接收者比往常多得多——据我交谈的几位律师说，是平时的四倍。
In December, a few days before Christmas, Kenia and Henrri were granted permission to travel. Pulling it off wasn't going to be easy. The whole thing was going to cost them more than $2,000 between the plane tickets, the documentation to re-enter the country, which was $360 each. They just recently re-upped their DACA status. That was another $495 each. Plus, they're missing three weeks of work, Kenia as a waitress at a restaurant and Henrri as a waiter at a catering hall. It's a big hit. They're paying their own way through school, living pretty much week to week in their parents' house on Long Island.
十二月，圣诞节前几天，肯尼亚和亨利获得了旅行许可。要实现这个目标并不容易。整个行程在机票、回美证件上花费了他们超过2000美元，每人360美元。他们最近刚续签了DACA身份。那是每人495美元。再加上他们要错过三周的工作，肯尼亚在餐馆当服务员，亨利在宴会厅当服务员。这是一个巨大的打击。他们半工半读，基本上靠在长岛父母家过着周光族的生活。
Their parents thought the trip was a good idea.
他们的父母认为这趟旅行是个好主意。
My dad always says, Kenia, don't worry. You can go back to El Salvador. You can work at an airport or a hotel somewhere where they need bilinguals.
我爸爸总是说，肯尼亚，别担心。你可以回萨尔瓦多。你可以在机场或酒店找工作，那是需要双语人才的地方。
And when you hear that idea--
当你听到这个主意时——
I'm like, oh, hello no. I'm like, well, that is not the life I pictured for myself. But for them, they see us as having opportunities. But again, they're thinking of survival. They're not thinking of dreams like the American-- you know how we think.
我会想，哦，见鬼去吧。我的意思是，那不是我为自己描绘的生活。但对他们来说，他们认为我们拥有机会。但再一次，他们考虑的是生存。他们没有像美国那样考虑梦想——你知道我们是怎么想的。
The next time I talk to them, just after New Year's, they were in El Salvador for the first time since they left as kids. I called them up on the phone.
我下一次和他们交谈是在新年过后不久，他们回到了萨尔瓦多，这是他们自儿时离开以来的第一次。我给他们打了电话。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, Kenia. Are you guys recording yourselves? So we are, actually, but--
嗨，肯尼亚。你们在录音吗？是的，实际上，但是——
Kenia brought a bunch of her film school equipment to record herself with and to document their trip.
肯尼亚带了一堆电影学院的设备来记录自己并记录他们的旅行。
So where are-- like where are you sitting right now?
你们在哪儿——你们现在坐在哪儿？
We're actually sitting in a tree.
我们实际上坐在树上。
What do you mean you're sitting in a tree? Like in a tree?
什么叫你们坐在树上？就像在树里？
Yeah. There's this small tree by the house, so we're just sitting here to get clearer sound because of the signal.
是的。房子旁边有一棵小树，所以我们坐在这里为了信号能有更清晰的声音。
How far off the ground are you sitting right now?
你们现在离地有多高？
How many feet is like that branch?
那个树枝离地多少英尺？
That branch? It would be like five feet.
那个树枝？大概有五英尺。
Yeah, like five feet. Like my height.
是的，就像五英尺。就像我的身高。
When Kenia and Henrri arrived at the airport in El Salvador, they got off the plane.
当肯尼亚和亨利到达萨尔瓦多的机场时，他们下了飞机。
And then I see a lot of faces. And I'm like, yo, they look like they're my family, but I didn't know who they were. And then I see papita barely standing like in the middle of the crowd of people who were waiting. And I'm like, papita!
然后我看到了很多面孔。我心想，哟，他们看起来像是我的家人，但我不知道他们是谁。然后我看到爸爸几乎站立不稳地站在等待人群的中间。我说，爸爸！
Papita! [CRYING]
爸爸！ [哭泣]
They hadn't expected to see their grandfather. He was still pretty much bedridden. But the family had pooled their money to pay for a microbus so he could get there to greet them. Kenia rushed through the crowd of people to hug him.
他们没指望见到他们的祖父。他基本上还卧床不起。但家里筹钱租了一辆小巴，这样他就能去迎接他们。肯尼亚冲过人群去拥抱他。
And he's like so little. I remember this tall, big man with a sombrero. And his face looks so old in the beginning that I was like, I'm surprised I'm even holding him right now.
他看起来那么瘦小。我记得那个戴着宽边帽、高大强壮的男人。他刚开始的脸看起来那么老，以至于我甚至惊讶自己正抱着他。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
OK. So today is day three of our trip to El Salvador. We're recording from bed again.
好的。今天是我们在萨尔瓦多旅行的第三天。我们又在床上录音了。
Every night, they'd record their impressions and there was a lot that was different from their hazy kid memories of El Salvador. Their grandmother still made coffee. The hammock where their grandfather used to lay after a hard in the cornfield was still there. But other stuff wasn't like they'd thought.
每天晚上，他们都会记录下他们的印象，很多东西与他们儿时对萨尔瓦多模糊的记忆不同。他们的祖母还在做咖啡。那个祖父以前在玉米地劳作后用来躺着的吊床还在那里。但其他东西不像他们想的那样。
Like we're amazed at how beautiful El Salvador is. We remembered it, but we didn't remember completely, and it's so beautiful. The whole time we were coming up here, we're like, I want to stay. I want to stay. But then you sit down with everybody and you have a conversation and gang talk is a lot of it. You can't escape that conversation of violence.
比如我们惊讶于萨尔瓦多是多么美丽。我们记得它，但记得不完整，而且它真的很美。我们来到这里的一路上都在说，我想留下来。我想留下来。但当你和大家坐在一起交谈时，帮派话题占了很大一部分。你无法逃避那种关于暴力的对话。
When they were little, the gangs had mostly been confined to cities, but now they'd reached little towns like theirs. Before the trip, Kenia had been careful not to ask her relatives for too many details about the violence. She was afraid to know. But being there, it was impossible to escape.
当他们小的时候，帮派大多局限在城市里，但现在它们已经蔓延到像他们这样的小镇了。旅行前，肯尼亚很小心不去向亲戚询问关于暴力的太多细节。她害怕知道。但身处那里，却无法逃避。
They kept hearing this one story about their cousin Daniel. Daniel gave a friend a ride on his motorcycle to a nearby town one night. It was a little later than Daniel felt comfortable. Normally nobody goes out after 8 o'clock. He told the story to Henrri as a warning. Henrri says Daniel was on his way back home and a group of guys signaled him to pull over.
他们一直听到关于表弟丹尼尔的一个故事。一天晚上，丹尼尔骑摩托车送一个朋友去附近的一个镇。比丹尼尔感觉舒服的时间晚了一点。通常晚上8点后没人会出门。他把这个故事作为警告告诉了亨利。亨利说丹尼尔在回家的路上，一群人示意他停车。
They forced him to stop there with the motorcycle. Once they had that, they started taking his stuff. He had a blue shirt on. I'm not sure if maybe that's some symbolism here for gangs, as well.
他们强迫他在那里停下摩托车。一旦他们有了摩托车，他们就开始抢他的东西。他穿了一件蓝色的衬衫。我不确定这里是否也有帮派的象征意义。
I think it was red.
我觉得是红色的。
It was blue. I don't know. Well, it was either a blue or red shirt. I'd have to make sure on that. But they took his shirt. They took his wallet, all his money. And then the next thing that they asked them for was for his papers, like the license and all that stuff, because that's how they see what town people are from.
是蓝色的。我不知道。好吧，要么是蓝色要么是红色衬衫。我得确认一下。但他们拿走了他的衬衫。他们拿走了他的钱包，所有的钱。接下他们向他索要证件，比如驾照之类的东西，因为他们就是那样看出人是来自哪个镇的。
The license showed that Daniel was from Los Achiotes, their rivals. Once they'd robbed him, it seemed like they might let him go.
驾照显示丹尼尔来自洛斯阿乔特斯（Los Achiotes），他们的对手。一旦他们抢劫了他，看起来他们可能会放他走。
But he heard that another guy who was just like, he's from the Achiotes. We know we hate those guys. Why are you going to leave him alive? So then at that point, the other guy that was about to let him go grabbed him, told him to get on his knees, and pointed a gun to his head. And right when he was about to kill him, this other car just came out of nowhere and shone his headlights onto them.
但他听到另一个人说，他来自阿乔特斯。我们知道我们讨厌那些家伙。为什么要让他活着？就在那个人要放他走的时候，另一个人抓住他，让他跪下，并用枪指着他的头。就在他要杀他的时候，另一辆车突然出现，用车头灯照向了他们。
Everyone stood still for a second, long enough for Daniel to reach into his pocket and grab the keys to his motorcycle. He ran to the bike, picked it up, and took off.
每个人都愣了一秒钟，这足够丹尼尔伸手去拿摩托车的钥匙。他跑到车边，扶起车，飞奔而去。
But as he was riding away, one of them got a big rock and threw it at him and hit him in the back because they were hoping to take him down and then kill him with that. And he said that, as he was driving away, he overheard them shouting, we're going to get you, and we're going to find you, and we're going to kill you with that. I'm just super freaked out. This is unbelievable. And just like, damn. The only reason he got out of there was because he got lucky.
但当他骑车逃走时，其中一个人捡起一块大石头扔向他，击中了他的后背，因为他们希望把他打倒然后杀了他。他说，在他逃跑时，他听到他们在大喊，我们会抓住你的，我们会找到你的，我们会杀了你。我简直被吓坏了。这简直难以置信。简直是，该死。他逃出来的唯一原因是因为他运气好。
Daniel had actually lived with them in the US for years when they were little. And in a lot of ways, Daniel is who Henrri and Kenia might be if they did end up back in El Salvador. He owns his own construction company, has a nice house, a family. By any standard, he's made it.
丹尼尔在他们小的时候确实和他们在没国住过几年。在很多方面，如果亨利和肯尼亚最终回到萨尔瓦多，他们可能就会变成丹尼尔那样。他拥有一家自己的建筑公司，有一所好房子，一个家庭。按照任何标准，他都成功了。
But it's just a fact. El Salvador has one of the highest murder rates in the world. A recent survey of Salvadorans found that 40% wanted to get out of the country. Now Kenia and Henrri could see why. This is from one of their late-night recordings.
但这只是一个事实。萨尔瓦多拥有世界上最高的谋杀率之一。最近一项对萨尔瓦多人的调查发现，40%的人想离开这个国家。现在肯尼亚和亨利明白了原因。这是他们深夜录音中的一段。
I feel like as time passes I do love it here and everything.
随着时间的推移，我觉得我确实爱这里。
It's like a romantic little dream you have of living here in peace.
这就像你梦想着在这里和平生活的一个浪漫小梦。
If we could live in peace, then yes. I would say definitely. But that's the thing. You do one wrong thing and you don't get a redo.
如果我们可以和平生活，那么是的。我肯定会说。但这就是问题所在。你做了一件错事，你就没有重来的机会。
Yeah, things are super hard here. Beautiful, beautiful place, but life is damn hard.
是的，这里的情况非常困难。美丽、美丽的地方，但生活真的很艰难。
It's tough.
很艰难。
When Kenia and Henrri really tried to imagine what their lives would be like in Los Achiotes, they started seeing all these other problems. Where their grandparents live is really isolated. There's nothing to do, no internet. Everything's expensive, but there's no work.
当肯尼亚和亨利真正试图想象他们在洛斯阿乔特斯的生活会是什么样子时，他们开始看到所有其他问题。他们的祖父母住的地方真的很偏远。没处可去，没有互联网。什么东西都很贵，但没有工作。
By the way, the closest movie theater here--
顺便说一句，离这里最近的电影院——
It's in the city.
在城市里。
It's in San Salvador. That's two hours away, bruh. Two hours away. I can't go right now and watch a movie anywhere here. Insane. I gotta change that. I mean, where are the sponsors? We gotta get some film festivals out here.
在圣萨尔瓦多。那是两个小时车程，哥们。两个小时。我现在不能去这里任何地方看电影。疯了。我得改变这一点。我的意思是，赞助商在哪儿？我们得在这里搞些电影节。
That'd be amazing.
那会很棒。
ASAP.
越快越好。
But Kenia says she probably couldn't make a living doing film here, or documentaries, or photography. And the university she looked into didn't have a film department. And Kenia feels like her chances of making it here are even more difficult because she's a woman. She's watched women stand behind while men did all the talking. At a party with her relatives she was chatting with her aunt.
但肯尼亚说她可能无法在这里靠电影、纪录片或摄影谋生。她查过的大学也没有电影系。肯尼亚觉得她在这里取得成功的机会更困难，因为她是女性。她看着男人们说话，女人们站在后面。在和亲戚聚会时，她在和阿姨聊天。
Her son is just chilling with his girlfriend and whatever, and she's like, oh, he must be so cold. Take a coffee for him. And I'm like, what? He has legs. Like they have to always-- my aunt always feels like she has to protect her little boy. This is how women are here with men. They have to, I don't know, be like the mom. Even as a partner, they're being moms to them. And that makes me uncomfortable.
她儿子正和女朋友在那儿闲晃，她却说，哦，他一定很冷。给他拿杯咖啡。我心想，什么？他有腿。她们总是——我阿姨总是觉得她必须保护她的小男孩。这就是这里的女人对待男人的方式。她们必须，我不知道，要像个母亲。即使作为伴侣，她们也在像母亲一样对待他们。这让我感到不舒服。
I think visiting is great, and I love it, but I don't know if I could do it for a long term. Henrri and I have been talking about it and I think it comes down to, if I had no choice left, I would definitely make the best life here. But right now it's so much easier in the United States because I'm already ahead in a world that I really under-- at least I understand more than El Salvador.
我认为来参观很好，我也很爱这里，但我不知道我是否能长期生活下去。亨利和我一直在讨论，我认为归根结底是，如果我别无选择，我绝对会在这里过上最好的生活。但现在在美国要容易得多，因为我已经在理解——至少我比理解萨尔瓦多更理解的世界里领先了。
So if DACA ends, they probably won't move to El Salvador. They'll try to make it in the US like every other undocumented immigrant-- working off the books, worrying they could get deported at any time. Kenia says she hates her choices, but the crappy option they know seems better than the crappy option they just checked out.
所以如果DACA结束，他们可能不会搬到萨尔瓦多。他们会像其他无证移民一样尝试在美国生存——打黑工，担心随时可能被驱逐出境。肯尼亚说她讨厌她的选择，但他们知道的那个糟糕选项似乎比他们刚考察过的那个糟糕选项要好。
They're back in New York now. They were allowed to stay overseas till January 20, which happened to be inauguration day. They came back a few days earlier just to be safe.
他们现在回到了纽约。他们获准在海外待到1月20日，那正好是就职典礼日。为了保险起见，他们提前几天回来了。
Seth Freed Wessler. He writes frequently about immigration.
塞斯·弗里德·韦斯勒。他经常撰写关于移民的文章。
By the way, even if the president decides to get rid of DACA, Republican Lindsey Graham and Democrat Dick Durbin have announced legislation that would keep DACA protections going for people like Kenia and Henrri. A few other Republicans have signed on-- Jeff Flake and Lisa Murkowski. The bill has not been formally introduced.
顺便说一句，即使总统决定废除DACA，共和党人林赛·格雷厄姆（Lindsey Graham）和民主党人迪克·德宾（Dick Durbin）也宣布了立法，将为像肯尼亚和亨利这样的人保留DACA保护。还有几位共和党人也签署了支持——杰夫·弗莱克（Jeff Flake）和莉莎·默考斯基（Lisa Murkowski）。该法案尚未正式提交。
Which brings us to Act Three. Act Three, Law and Border.
这让我们来到了第三幕。第三幕，法律与边界（Law and Border）。
So let's turn now from DACA kids to a group that you would expect would be pretty stoked for the new president, Border Patrol agents. Their union endorsed Donald Trump last March. He's the first presidential candidate they've ever endorsed during the primaries.
那么，让我们从DACA孩子转向一个你预料会为新总统感到兴奋的群体：边境巡逻队特工。他们的工会去年三月支持了唐纳德·特朗普。他是他们在初选期间支持的第一位总统候选人。
Stephanie Foo went to Texas to see how they're feeling.
斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）去了得克萨斯州，看看他们的感受。
Before I tell you what bugged Chris Cabrera about his job under President Obama, let me describe him for you. Chris has been a Border Patrol agent since 2001. He's 43, has chewing tobacco tucked under his lip, and a tattoo of army airborne wings on his arm. He used to be a paratrooper. And he likes the action part of his job. It's like playing hide-and-seek, he says, except you're always it.
在我告诉你克里斯·卡布雷拉（Chris Cabrera）在奥巴马总统任期内对他的工作有什么不满之前，让我为你描述一下他。克里斯自2001年以来一直是边境巡逻特工。他43岁，嘴唇下塞着嚼烟，手臂上有军队空降兵徽章的纹身。他以前是一名伞兵。他喜欢他工作中动作冒险的那部分。他说，就像玩捉迷藏，只是你总是那个抓人的。
But he also sees it as a humanitarian job. He keeps his son's old toys in the back of his truck for when he picks up children crossing the border. He's rescued migrants who were dumped in the Rio Grande River by smugglers. Like a third of all Border Patrol agents, he's Latino himself, which is something he gets flak for.
但他也将此视为一份人道主义工作。他在卡车后座放着他儿子的旧玩具，以备他捡到越境的孩子时使用。他营救过被偷渡者丢弃在格兰德河的移民。像三分之一的边境巡逻特工一样，他自己也是拉丁裔，这让他遭到了一些抨击。
I've even had it from some of my in-laws. How could you do that to your own people?
我甚至从我的一些姻亲那里也遇到过。你怎么能那样对待你的人民？
Like over Thanksgiving or something?
比如感恩节之类的？
Maybe not Thanksgiving, but just out there barbecuing or something. I tell them, look, I can do my job with compassion. I know I can do my job the right way. I said, but if I wasn't there, who's to say the guy that fills my shoes is not going have the same level of compassion that I do?
可能不是感恩节，就是出去烧烤的时候。我告诉他们，看，我可以怀着同情心做好我的工作。我知道我可以以正确的方式做好我的工作。我说，但如果我不在这里，谁能说代替我的人会拥有和我一样程度的同情心呢？
But anyway, back to the thing that drives Chris nuts about his job. In the last two weeks of the Obama presidency, he takes me out to this spot, one of the busiest places people cross the border. 500 people most days, he says. We're maybe half a mile from the Rio Grande, the border between Texas and Mexico.
但无论如何，回到让克里斯对他的工作感到抓狂的事情上。在奥巴马总统任期的最后两周，他带我去了这个地方，这是人们越境最繁忙的地方之一。他说，大多数日子里有500人。我们离格兰德河——得克萨斯州和墨西哥之间的边界——大约半英里。
Yeah, I would say here not too long from now somebody will come through here.
是的，我说过不了多久就会有人从这儿过来。
Is there a time of day that they usually come?
他们通常会在什么时间过来？
Usually around now. Yeah, see? You got some footprints right here.
通常就在这时候。是的，看？这里就有脚印。
Oh. They're small. They look like kid's prints.
哦。它们很小。看起来像孩子的脚印。
Yeah. Look at that. I mean, that one's new right there. That one's real fresh.
是的。看那个。我是说，那个是新的。那个真的很新鲜。
Chris isn't on duty right now, just wandering around in a Detroit Tigers T-shirt. And it's getting pretty hot out, so we walk back to his pickup to sit and wait. We're in his car for seven minutes and 37 seconds when it happens.
克里斯现在没在执行任务，只是穿着底特律老虎队的T恤四处游荡。天越来越热，所以我们走回他的皮卡车里坐着等。我们在他的车里坐了7分37秒，事情就发生了。
Oh, my god. There's three people coming down the road.
哦，我的天。路上有三个人走过来。
It looks like we've got a group of four.
看起来我们有一组四个人。
I'm calling it in. Yeah, this is Cabrera, mike 207. I'm off duty. I'm down here record--
我在呼叫总部。是的，我是卡布雷拉，mike 207。我没在执勤。我在这里记录——
It's a young man and his teenage sister, and an older man and his teenage son. They have to have seen our car, but they don't run or hide. The travelers amble right up to us. Chris goes up to say hi.
那是一个年轻男子和他十几岁的妹妹，还有一个年纪较大的男人和他十几岁的儿子。他们一定看到了我们的车，但他们没有跑也没有躲。旅行者径直向我们走来。克里斯上前打招呼。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
The older man speaks for the group. They've just arrived from Guatemala. Chris asks the men where they were going.
年长的男人代表该组发言。他们刚从危地马拉抵达。克里斯问男人们他们要去哪儿。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
Si.
是的。
Para Atlanta.
去亚特兰大。
Atlanta?
亚特兰大？
Chris says, I'm Border Patrol.
克里斯说，我是边境巡逻队的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
Ah, Border Patrol?
啊，边境巡逻队？
Si.
是的。
Chris shows the man his badge, and the man looks relieved. He sighs, rests back on his heels. Chris asks him if he'd like some water.
克里斯给那个人看了他的徽章，那个人看起来松了一口气。他叹了口气，靠在脚后跟上休息。克里斯问他是否需要水。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
The man giggles bashfully, showing off some missing teeth and says, that'd be nice.
那个男人羞涩地笑了，露出缺了几颗牙的牙齿，说，那会很棒的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
Then the Border Patrol rolls up and hops out of their vans, clipboards in hand. They say hello and then hand the family plastic evidence bags, asking them to put their belongings inside them. The whole confrontation is surprisingly non-confrontational. The Border Patrol agents are joking around, asking kindly if everyone in their group made it.
然后边境巡逻队开着货车过来了，拿着剪贴板跳了下来。他们打招呼，然后递给这一家人塑料证据袋，让他们把随身物品放进去。整个对峙过程出奇地和谐。边境巡逻特工开着玩笑，亲切地询问他们组里的每个人是否都顺利过来了。
I expected the travelers to look weary and dusty from a long trek, but the girl is wearing these silver rhinestone-covered sandals with pink socks underneath. Her socks are clean. Just on the other side of the border is Reynosa, a major Mexican city, and the man says they took a bus there. So they probably just walked here from the nearest stop.
我原以为旅行者长途跋涉会显得疲惫且满身尘土，但女孩穿着亮闪闪的水钻凉鞋，里面穿着粉红色的袜子。她的袜子很干净。边界的另一边是雷诺萨（Reynosa），一个主要的墨西哥城市，那个人说他们坐巴士到了那里。所以他们可能只是从最近的车站走到这里。
I asked the girl if she's OK. She smiles at me and says she is. She looks nervous, but not afraid. I ask her why she's crossing. Her brother answers for her.
我问女孩她还好吗。她对我微笑并说她很好。她看起来很紧张，但并不害怕。我问她为什么要越境。她哥哥替她回答。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
He's saying that the gangs in Guatemala wanted his sister to join and because of that she felt her life was threatened. Bingo. This group is seeking asylum, which is why they were so glad to see Chris. Before they send migrants over, coyotes tell them to look for the Border Patrol.
他说危地马拉的帮派想让他的妹妹加入，因为那个原因，她觉得自己的生命受到了威胁。宾果。这一组人正在寻求庇护，这就是为什么他们看到克里斯那么高兴。在他们把移民送过来之前，蛇头会告诉他们找边境巡逻队。
In the last few years, there's been a big increase in people fleeing from El Salvador, Guatemala, and Honduras, seeking asylum, mostly from gang violence. It shot up from around 8,000 adults in 2012 to at least 68,000 in 2016. Chris believes that a lot of these migrants have been handed a script by coyotes who tell them to say what this group said, that the girl would be killed if she went back home. Those are the magic words, and they work to get her entry into the country.
过去几年，从萨尔瓦多、危地马拉和洪都拉斯逃离、寻求庇护的人数大幅增加，主要是为了躲避帮派暴力。它从2012年的约8000名成年人飙升至2016年的至少68000名。克里斯相信很多这些移民是被蛇头递了剧本，告诉他们说这一组人所说的话，即如果女孩回到家乡就会被杀。那些就是魔法词汇，它们能让他们成功入境。
And this is the part of the job that bugs Chris. It means he isn't doing what he signed up to do-- protect the border.
而这正是克里斯工作中让他困扰的部分。这意味着他没有做他签署合同要做的——保护边境。
You're like the welcoming committee.
你就像欢迎委员会。
In a sense, yeah. We're a welcoming committee.
某种意义上，是的。我们是欢迎委员会。
That's your job.
那是你的工作。
Yeah.
是的。
That must be frustrating.
那一定很令人沮丧。
Yeah. You're figuring, what's my job come to? I'm releasing 80% of the people that are coming through.
是的。你心想，我的工作变成了什么？我正在释放80%穿过这里的人。
Not releasing right away. There is a process. Some will be detained for weeks or longer, vetted in various ways. But the reality of the situation is you can only get asylum for a few very specific reasons. You have to be persecuted for your race, religion, nationality, membership in a particular social group, or political opinion. Most of these Central Americans probably don't qualify. Over the last five years, 80% have been rejected and deported after their hearings.
不是立即释放。有一个过程。有些人会被拘留几周甚至更长时间，经过各种审查。但现实情况是，你只能因为一些非常具体的原因获得庇护。你必须因为你的种族、宗教、国籍、特定社会群体的成员身份或政治观点而受到迫害。大多数这些中美洲人可能并不符合条件。在过去五年中，80%的人在听证会后被拒绝并驱逐出境。
So the girl who said the gangs were after her, she probably wouldn't get asylum. But she is entitled to a hearing to see. So she'll be taken to a detention center, processed, and eventually released. She'll be assigned a court date, but because the system is so backed up, that date can be more than six years from now. And during that time, Chris says, she and the others can disappear into America, get work permits. The kids will enter school. They'll start a life.
所以那个说帮派在追她的女孩，她可能得不到庇护。但她有权参加听证会看一看。所以她会被带到拘留中心，进行处理，最终被释放。她会被安排一个出庭日期，但因为系统积压严重，那个日期可能是六年之后。在那期间，克里斯说，她和其他人可以消失在美国，获得工作许可。孩子们会进入学校。他们会开始生活。
Lots of people don't show up for their court date. They join the 11 million undocumented people living in this country. It's catch and release, Chris says. He and I and another border agent watch the four of them get into the van to be taken away.
很多人不会按时出庭。他们加入了生活在这个国家的1100万无证人口。这是“抓了又放”，克里斯说。我和他以及另一名边境特工看着他们四个人上车被带走。
So how long will it take for them to get to Atlanta?
那么他们到达亚特兰大需要多长时间？
They'll be in custody, what? 24, or-- I'm sorry--
他们会被拘留，什么？24小时，或者——抱歉——
72 Hours.
72小时。
72. And then they'll hit the bus station. By this time next week, they'll probably be enrolled in school somewhere.
72小时。然后他们就会到达汽车站。下周这个时候，他们可能已经入校上学了。
The way Chris sees it, while agents are tied up with asylum seekers, there are all these other people coming over the border that they don't have time to chase-- a lot of Mexicans and other people who aren't claiming asylum. And then there are the straight-up criminals trying to cross the border. The Mexican cartels smuggle drugs and guns.
在克里斯看来，当特工们被寻求庇护者困住时，还有所有这些其他人越过边界，他们没有时间去追赶——很多墨西哥人和其他不申请庇护的人。然后还有那些试图越境的直接罪犯。墨西哥卡特尔走私毒品和枪支。
I mean, I want to get back to doing what we do and chasing and catching the bad guys, the ones that are trying to do harm to our country or bring drugs and put them on our streets. That's the ones we want to be going after. That's the ones we want to be stopping.
我的意思是，我想回到我们所做的事情上来，去追逐并抓住坏人，那些试图对我们国家造成伤害或把毒品带进来放到我们街头上的人。那些是我们想要追捕的。那些是我们想要阻止的。
But instead, you're like--
但相反，你却——
Making bologna sandwiches. Granted, it's a necessary job, but I'm sure you can train somebody to do that for a lot less than what you're paying us.
在做博洛尼亚三明治。诚然，这是必要的工作，但我相信你可以培训别人花比付给我们的工资少得多的钱来做这件事。
It's not like President Obama has changed the rules to allow in a flood of asylum seekers. Those rules have been the same for years. But Chris believes Obama's been too forgiving with undocumented immigrants in general-- not just at the border, but also the ones who are already living in our country. His administration issued all sorts of guidelines saying immigration officers shouldn't go after pregnant women, seriously mentally ill people, high school or college students.
并不是奥巴马总统改变了规则以允许寻求庇护者涌入。这些规则多年来一直是一样的。但克里斯认为奥巴马对无证移民总体上太宽容了——不仅是在边境，也包括那些已经生活在我们国家的人。他的政府发布了各种指导方针，说移民官员不应该针对孕妇、严重的精神病人、高中或大学生。
In 2012, Obama created DACA, which of course benefited undocumented kids who came to the US. And in 2014, he pushed for DAPA, which would have allowed undocumented parents to stay in the country if their kids were legal residents.
2012年，奥巴马创立了DACA，当然这使来到美国的无证孩子受益。2014年，他推动了DAPA，这将允许无证父母如果他们的孩子是合法居民就可以留在国内。
To Chris, all these policies send a message to Central Americans. Come to the United States. Walk across the border. It's fine.
对克里斯来说，所有这些政策都在向中美洲人传递一个信息。来美国吧。走过边境。没关系。
Any time you're relaxing the rules, relaxing the laws, it causes some type of surge. They know that we're releasing people. They know that. They know the system is flawed. People started letting their relatives know back home, hey, I came through. I said this. They let me through. So more people kept coming.
任何时候你放松规则、放松法律，它都会引起某种激增。他们知道我们正在释放人员。他们知道这一点。他们知道系统有缺陷。人们开始让家里的亲戚知道，嘿，我穿过来了。我说了这些话。他们让我进来了。所以更多的人不断涌入。
Chris and the other guys from his union have complained about all of the problems they're facing to their bosses. They've testified at Senate hearings. Nothing ever changed.
克里斯和他工会的其他同事向他们的老板抱怨了他们面临的所有问题。他们在参议院听证会上作证。什么都没有改变。
So imagine you're Chris, feeling ignored, and one day you turn on the television and the border is the centerpiece of a presidential campaign.
所以想象你是克里斯，感到被忽视，一天你打开电视，边界是总统竞选的核心。
Build the wall! Build the wall! Build the wall!
修墙！修墙！修墙！
It was interesting. Granted, I think that's kind of like a symbolic thing-- "build the wall" that they chant. Nobody knows what's going to happen with the wall, but just for the fact that we have that support nationally as far as Border Patrol agents--
这很有趣。诚然，我认为这有点像象征性的东西——他们高喊“修墙”。没人知道墙会怎么样，但仅仅因为我们作为边境巡逻特工在全国范围内获得了这种支持——
Oh, you didn't see it as like, I'm stoked about the wall. You were like, oh, look at all of those people who support me.
哦，你没把它看作是，我对那堵墙很兴奋。你是说，哦，看看所有那些支持我的人。
Yeah. I think they're realizing that what we have is a real job and it's a difficult job, and we're actually on their radar.
是的。我认为他们意识到我们拥有一份真正的工作，这是一份困难的工作，而我们实际上在他们的雷达范围内。
Chris doesn't even think a continuous wall is practical. There are walls and fences along 704 miles of the border, including along parts of the Rio Grande right near here, and, Chris says, people find a way around them.
克里斯甚至认为连续的墙并不切实际。边界沿线有704英里的墙和栅栏，包括就在这里附近的格兰德河沿岸的部分，而且，克里斯说，人们总能找到绕过它们的方法。
We put an 18-foot wall up. The next day, we had 19-foot ladders all over the place. It got so bad. There were just ladders everywhere-- behind the station, stacked up as high as you can reach. After a month, they said stop bringing the damn ladders in.
我们建了一堵18英尺高的墙。第二天，到处都是19英尺高的梯子。糟糕透了。到处都是梯子——在车站后面，堆得尽可能高。一个月后，他们说别再带该死的梯子进来了。
The Border Patrol felt like Trump was speaking directly to them. Actually, he did speak directly to them.
边境巡逻队觉得特朗普是在直接对他们说话。实际上，他确实直接对他们说了话。
Our first guest is a best-selling author, Emmy-nominated television star, business mogul, and real estate tycoon. He is also the presumptive Republican nominee for President of the United States. Ladies and gentlemen, Mr. Donald J. Trump. Welcome to The Green Line, Mr. Trump.
我们的第一位嘉宾是畅销书作家、艾美奖提名电视明星、商业巨头和房地产大亨。他也是共和党提名的美国总统候选人。女士们先生们，唐纳德·J·特朗普先生。欢迎来到“绿线”，特朗普先生。
Well, thank you very much. I appreciate it.
好吧，非常感谢。我很感激。
This is The Green Line. It's a podcast that's hosted by a bunch of Border Patrol agents, including Chris. All of them are union reps or officials in the union. Border Patrol agent Shawn Moran and Thane Gallagher were interviewing Trump, and he was telling them things they'd never heard another presidential candidate say before.
这是“绿线”。这是一个由一群边境巡逻特工主持的播客，包括克里斯。他们所有人都是工会代表或工会官员。边境巡逻特工肖恩·莫兰（Shawn Moran）和塞恩·加拉格尔（Thane Gallagher）在采访特朗普，他告诉了他们以前从未听过其他总统候选人说的话。
When I'm-- if I'm elected, I have to say, because I have to be modest, but if and when I'm elected, I'm going to be relying very much on the professionalism of the Border Patrol to tell us what to do. They know better than anybody. They know better than any consultant you can hire. We'll be meeting and we'll be talking, but I just want to tell you I have you 100% in my mind, and I have your back. Believe me.
如果我当选了，我必须说，因为我必须谦虚，但如果我当选了，我将非常依赖边境巡逻队的专业精神来告诉我们做什么。他们比任何人都清楚。他们比你能雇佣的任何顾问都清楚。我们会见面交谈，但我只是想告诉你，我100%记着你们，我支持你们。相信我。
So I have no doubt that you folks are going to be able to do a fantastic job. I hope you agree with me. Do you agree with me on that?
所以我毫不怀疑你们这些人将能够做得非常出色。我希望你们同意我的观点。你们同意我的看法吗？
We do.
我们同意。
Chris wasn't hosting that day. He was listening at home. He thought the two hosts that were handling it sounded a little giddy.
克里斯那天没主持。他在家里听。他觉得处理这件事的那两位主持人听起来有点飘飘然。
Like two little star-struck girls just met Justin Bieber or something. Here you have the potential next leader of the free world coming on your show and talking to you-- and on top of that, he's Donald Trump. He's Donald Trump. He's a billionaire. That's big stuff.
就像两个见到贾斯汀·比伯或什么的迷妹。这里有未来自由世界的潜在领导人来到你们节目并和你们交谈——更重要的是，他是唐纳德·特朗普。他是唐纳德·特朗普。他是亿万富翁。那可是大事。
Trump even met up with the Border Patrol guys, in person, not on the air, a few times during his campaign, including with Art Del Cueto, one of the other hosts of the show. Here's Art.
特朗普甚至在竞选期间几次亲自会见了边境巡逻队的家伙，而不是在广播里，包括与该节目的另一位主持人阿尔特·德尔·奎托（Art Del Cueto）。这是阿尔特。
Doing this for quite some time, we run into a lot of people when we explain what we do and explain all the issues that we have, and a lot of time these individuals, it almost seems like they're off in another voyage waiting to ask the next question. But every time that we've sat down and spoken to Mr. Trump, every time he would sit there, listen to our answers, and thoroughly ask follow-up questions. So you could tell he's really in tune and he really is paying attention.
做这件事有一段时间了，我们确实遇到了很多人，当我们解释我们做什么并解释我们遇到的所有问题时，很多时候这些人，看起来他们好像处于另一段航程中，等着问下一个问题。但每次我们坐下来和特朗普先生交谈时，每次他都会坐在那里，听我们的回答，并彻底地提出后续问题。所以你能看出他真的很投入，而且他真的在关注。
On election night, a bunch of the Border Patrol union guys were in New York at Trump's victory party. Here's Art.
在选举之夜，一群边境巡逻队的工会家伙在纽约特朗普的胜利派对上。这是阿尔特。
Even on his acceptance speech-- when he was done with his acceptance speech, he walked off the stage and he does his rounds of shaking people's hands and high-fiving, but he took the time to stop where I'm particularly standing. He looked at me, pointed, he right away recognized who I was, and he said, here are my guys. These are my guys. He came over. He shook our hands. And he said, get ready to go to work.
甚至在他的获胜演说中——当他演讲完时，他走下舞台，他开始轮流与人握手和击掌，但他花时间停在我站的地方。他看着我，指着我，他立刻认出了我是谁，他说，这是我的伙计们。这些是我的伙计。他走了过来。他握了我们的手。他说，准备好去工作吧。
Chris was there that night, too. Unlike Art, that was the first time he'd met Donald Trump.
那天晚上克里斯也在那里。和阿尔特不同，那是他第一次见到唐纳德·特朗普。
He was kind of interesting, but--
他很有趣，但是——
[CHUCKLES] He's kind of interesting.
（轻笑）他很有趣。
I don't get too bent out of shape. I just kind of, hey, how you doing? Shake a hand.
我没太走心。我只是，嘿，你好吗？握个手。
You don't seem that excited about shaking the president's hand.
你看起来对握总统的手没那么兴奋。
Yeah, I know. I mean, he's the president. I'm sure I'll probably get to meet him again.
是啊，我知道。我的意思是，他是总统。我相信我以后可能还有机会见到他。
Right. He's not that excited because, as far as Chris is concerned, that was just their first hello. He knows that he, or his guys anyway, will be sitting down with Trump and talking very soon.
没错。他没那么兴奋，因为就克里斯而言，那只是他们的第一次问候。他知道他，或者说他的伙计们，很快就会坐下来和特朗普交谈。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program.
斯蒂芬妮·富是我们节目的制作人之一。
Coming up, civil servants who do not like President Trump tell us stuff they are not telling their new Republican bosses about how they might quietly try to subvert his goals from inside the bureaucracy. That's when we come back from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，不喜欢特朗普总统的公务员告诉我们一些他们没告诉新共和党老板的事情，关于他们可能如何在官僚机构内部悄悄试图颠覆他的目标。这就是我们从芝加哥公共广播电台回来后节目继续的内容。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Revolution Begins at Noon," stories for the inauguration of Donald Trump as president.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“革命从正午开始”，关于唐纳德·特朗普总统就职的故事。
We've arrived at Act Four of our show. Act Four, You're Still Fired.
我们来到了我们节目的第四幕。第四幕，你仍然被解雇了（You're Still Fired）。
It seems like so many people of the country have extreme feelings about this inauguration day. They're either incredibly excited or incredibly fearful about this new president. But one place that we found lots of people sort of in the middle was Indiana at the company that makes Carrier air conditioners and furnaces. You may remember the first campaign promise that President Trump fulfilled-- he did it even before he took office-- is when he convinced that company that makes Carrier air conditioners and furnaces from moving hundreds of jobs to Mexico.
看起来全国这么多人对这个就职日有极端的感情。他们要么对这位新总统感到极其兴奋，要么极其恐惧。但我们发现有很多处于中间状态的人的一个地方是印第安纳州，在生产开利（Carrier）空调和熔炉的公司。你可能记得特朗普总统兑现的第一个竞选承诺——他甚至在就职前就做到了——那是当他说服那家生产开利空调和熔炉的公司不把数百个工作岗位转移到墨西哥时。
Sam Black went and checked in with the workers who make those products and found lots of people in the middle and, interestingly, even among the people whose jobs were not saved, lots were still feeling hopeful about Donald Trump. Here's Sam.
萨姆·布莱克（Sam Black）去查看了生产这些产品的工人，发现很多人处于中间状态，有趣的是，即使在那些工作没有保住的人中，许多人仍然对唐纳德·特朗普感到充满希望。这是萨姆。
The workers I met who voted for Trump, whether their jobs were saved or not, most of them were pretty lukewarm about the new president. Not hardcore "make America great again" types. One white man in his 50s told me that Trump's comments about women made him ashamed to be a man, but he voted for him anyway. A black guy in his 30s said he'd walked into the voting booth planning to go for Clinton, put his pen to her name, but then thought he couldn't trust her and changed to Trump.
我遇到的投票给特朗普的工人，无论他们的工作是否保住，他们中大多数人对这位新总统表现得相当冷淡。不是那种铁杆的“让美国再次伟大”类型。一位50多岁的白人男子告诉我，特朗普关于女性的评论让他为自己身为男人感到羞耻，但他还是投票给了他。一位30多岁的黑人男子说他走进投票站时计划投给克林顿，笔尖已经触到了她的名字，但他随后想他无法信任她，改投了特朗普。
Then there was Georgina. She says she was initially for Bernie Sanders all the way, but in November she went for Trump.
还有乔治娜（Georgina）。她说她最初一直支持伯尼·桑德斯，但在十一月她选择了特朗普。
Were you excited when he was elected?
当他当选时你兴奋吗？
Kinda.
有点吧。
Georgina's been working at the same factory for 25 years. She makes just over $16 an hour plus benefits, enough to live a decent life in the small town of Huntington, where her company, UTEC, is the largest employer. She's 48, raised three kids, and has 10 grandkids.
乔治娜在同一家工厂工作了25年。她每小时挣16美元多一点外加福利，足够在亨廷顿这个小镇过上体面的生活，她的公司UTEC是那里最大的雇主。她48岁，养育了三个孩子，有10个孙子孙女。
Her employer, UTEC, is the sister company to Carrier. It makes the circuit boards that go into Carrier air conditioners and furnaces. She really likes her job.
她的雇主UTEC是开利公司的姐妹公司。它生产用于开利空调和熔炉的电路板。她真的很喜欢她的工作。
As far as factories go, that is the easiest work that you will ever find. Ever. I mean, it's air conditioned and it's got good heat. It's clean. You can wear white to work and not worry about it.
就工厂而言，那是你能找到的最轻松的工作。永远。我的意思是，它有空调，有很好的暖气。它是干净的。你可以穿着白色衣服去上班而不必担心它。
Carrier became part of the presidential campaign about a year ago when the company announced it was closing its Indianapolis plant. That same morning, UTEC, where Georgina works, called all the workers into the cafeteria. Same deal. 700 people would lose their jobs.
大约一年前，当公司宣布关闭其印第安纳波利斯工厂时，开利成了总统竞选的一部分。同一天早上，乔治娜工作的UTEC把所有工人都叫进了食堂。同样的情况。700人将失去工作。
It was devastating. People were crying. Everybody was just stunned and very, very quiet. And once he said that, honestly, I don't know what was said after that. I have no idea because so many things were racing through my head.
这太让人崩溃了。人们在哭。每个人都震惊了，非常、非常安静。一旦他说出那句话，老实说，我不知道在那之后说了什么。我一点主意都没有，因为我的脑子里闪过太多的念头。
10 months later, after Donald Trump won the election-- you may have seen this-- he went to the Carrier plant in Indianapolis to announce he'd made a deal.
10个月后，在唐纳德·特朗普赢得大选之后——你可能见过这个——他去了印第安纳波利斯的开利工厂宣布他达成了协议。
I want to thank Greg Hayes of United Technologies because when I called him, he was right there.
我要感谢联合技术公司的格雷格·海斯（Greg Hayes），因为当我打电话给他时，他就在那里。
I waited to see how many jobs were saved, whose jobs were saved. I got excited, and I was sitting on pins and needles.
我等着看有多少工作岗位被保住了，谁的工作被保住了。我变得很兴奋，如坐针毡。
--is it's so great. So many people in that big, beautiful plant behind us, they're so happy. They're going to have a great Christmas.
——这太棒了。在我们身后那座巨大、美丽的工厂里有那么多人，他们太高兴了。他们将会有一个很棒的圣诞节。
Here was Trump's bargain. In exchange for a $7 million tax break, Carrier would keep about 800 jobs in Indianapolis. More than 1,300 jobs would still go to Mexico, including Georgina's.
这就是特朗普的交易。作为700万美元税收减免的交换，开利将保留印第安纳波利斯约800个工作岗位。超过1300个工作岗位仍将流向墨西哥，包括乔治娜的。
And when I realized, yeah, then I got a little upset and then disappointment.
当我意识到时，是的，我有点难过，然后感到失望。
These companies aren't going to be leaving anymore. They're not going to be taking people's hearts out.
这些公司不会再离开了。他们不会再把人们的心挖走。
Then watching all of them celebrate--
然后看着他们所有人庆祝——
Thank you. Thank you very much.
谢谢。非常感谢。
That was a little depressing. It was hard to watch. Yeah, I was sad.
那有点令人沮丧。很难看下去。是的，我很难过。
Georgina says that what bothered her was that Trump acted like he accomplished more than he did. And it felt like it was all about him, a publicity stunt, a victory lap at her expense. He could have at least mentioned the workers he didn't help.
乔治娜说让她困扰的是，特朗普表现得好像他取得了比实际更多的成就。感觉这全是关于他自己，一场公关噱头，以她的代价进行的胜利巡游。他至少可以提到他没有帮助的那些工人。
Acknowledge us-- not just us, but the ones at Indy that you didn't save, and these other factories that are all shutting down, not just us. Acknowledge them.
承认我们——不只是我们，还有印第安纳波利斯那些你没有救下来的人，以及这些正在关闭的其他工厂，不只是我们。承认他们。
That would have meant something to you.
那对你来说会有意义。
It would have. I don't think that I would have thought that it was just for good press then. I would think, he's really going to try. He's going to do the best he can for everybody.
会有意义。我不认为那时候我会认为这只是为了好的报道。我会想，他真的要尝试了。他要为每个人尽他所能。
Georgina told me she thinks Trump's deal mostly benefited the company, which pocketed millions and still laid off 1,300 people. Another worker put it this way. Imagine getting fired by a company with billion-dollar profits and then finding out that your tax dollars are picking up their tab. It's like you're subsidizing your own layoff.
乔治娜告诉我，她认为特朗普的交易主要是让公司受益，公司装进了数百万美元，却仍然裁掉了1300人。另一位工人这样说。想象一下被一家拥有数十亿美元利润的公司解雇，然后发现你的税款在为他们的账单买单。这就像你在补贴你自己的裁员。
But despite all this, Georgina still holds out hope for the new president. In his campaign, Donald Trump talked about putting 35% tariffs on companies that send jobs offshore. Georgina hopes that was more than just a campaign promise. And in fact, after she and I talked, Trump brought it up at his first press conference.
但尽管如此，乔治娜仍然对这位新总统抱有希望。在竞选中，唐纳德·特朗普谈到了对向海外转移工作的公司征收35%的关税。乔治娜希望那不仅仅是一个竞选承诺。事实上，在她和我谈话后，特朗普在他的第一次新闻发布会上提到了这一点。
The word is now out that when you want to move your plant to Mexico or some other place and you want to fire all of your workers from Michigan and Ohio and all these places that I won for good reason, it's not going to happen that way anymore. You're going to pay a very large border tax. A major border tax on these companies that are leaving and getting away with murder.
现在的消息是，当你想把你的工厂搬到墨西哥或其他地方，并且想解雇密歇根州、俄亥俄州以及所有这些我以正当理由赢得的州的所有工人时，事情不会再那样发生了。你将支付一笔非常大的边境税。对这些离开并逃脱惩罚的公司征收巨额边境税。
I think that Trump really does want to help keep the jobs in the US. And I don't know yet. He might be the best president we've ever had. I have no idea.
我认为特朗普确实想帮助在美国保留工作岗位。我还不知道。他可能是我们有史以来最好的总统。我一点主意都没有。
Georgina doesn't remember any other presidential candidate even bothering to talk about workers like her, except Bernie Sanders.
乔治娜不记得有任何其他总统候选人费心谈论过像她这样的工人，除了伯尼·桑德斯。
On inauguration day, Georgina was at work. She could be laid off as early as April. Her plan? Go to night school, get trained for administrative work in a hospital, making less than she does now.
在就职典礼当天，乔治娜在上班。她最早可能在四月被裁员。她的计划？去夜校，接受培训以便在医院做行政工作，挣得比现在少。
How do you expect you'll feel watching him being inaugurated as president?
看着他就职成为总统，你预计会有什么感觉？
Hopeful, because I want him to prove me wrong, that he is going to try and save these other people's jobs. Not ours. I know that's not going to happen, but there's other places that are talking about leaving and maybe he can save those.
充满希望，因为我想让他证明我是错的，他确实会尝试拯救这些其他人的工作。不是我们的。我知道那不会发生，但还有其他地方在谈论离开，也许他可以拯救那些。
But the truth is, Georgina says she rarely thinks about the man she helped elect. Maybe once a week when someone at work jokes about his latest tweet.
但事实是，乔治娜说她很少想到她帮助选出的那个人。也许每周一次，当同事开他最新推文的玩笑时。
Sam Black. He's a documentary filmmaker in New York.
萨姆·布莱克。他是纽约的一名纪录片制作人。
Act Five, Debate is Not Allowed During a Vote.
第五幕，投票期间禁止辩论（Debate is Not Allowed During a Vote）。
So for the Democrats, what is life about to look like without control of the White House, House, or Senate? Well, one little preview happened earlier this month at around 1:00 in the morning on the Senate floor. It was the vote that would start the process of dismantling Obamacare. Democrats knew they would lose, but for the next few years things are going to happen that they do not like and are powerless to stop. All they could do that night was try to make a statement while voting no, though the other side controls even how much of a statement they get to make. Here's an excerpt of how the vote went down.
所以对于民主党人来说，失去对白宫、众议院或参议院的控制后，生活会是什么样子？嗯，本月初凌晨1点左右在参议院大厅发生了一个小预演。那是将启动废除奥巴马医改（Obamacare）程序的投票。民主党人知道他们会输，但在接下来的几年里，他们不喜欢的事情会发生，而他们无力阻止。那天晚上他们能做的唯一事情就是试图在投票反对时发表声明，尽管对方控制着甚至让他们发表声明的程度。这是投票过程的节选。
Mrs. Gillibrand.
吉利布兰德夫人（Mrs. Gillibrand）。
I vote no on behalf of all the women who need health--
我投票反对，代表所有需要健康——
Senator is not exempt. Debate is not allowed during the vote.
参议员没有豁免权。投票期间禁止辩论。
Mrs. Gillibrand, no. Mr. Schatz.
吉利布兰德夫人，反对。沙茨先生（Mr. Schatz）。
I vote no on behalf of people who need mental health care.
我投票反对，代表需要精神卫生保健的人们。
Debate is not allowed during the vote.
投票期间禁止辩论。
Mr. Schatz, no.
沙茨先生，反对。
Gentleman from Illinois.
来自伊利诺伊州的先生。
On behalf of the Downstate hospitals of Illinois, I vote--
代表伊利诺伊州南部下游的医院，我投票——
Debate is not in order during a vote.
投票期间辩论不符合秩序。
Mr. Durbin, no. Ms. Klobuchar.
德宾先生（Mr. Durbin），反对。克洛布查尔女士（Ms. Klobuchar）。
Because there is no plan in the alternative--
因为替代方案中没有计划——
Debate is not allowed--
禁止辩论——
--I vote no.
——我投票反对。
--will be in order.
——将符合秩序。
Ms. Klobuchar, no.
克洛布查尔女士，反对。
[INAUDIBLE] order. Debate is not in order during a vote.
（听不清）秩序。投票期间辩论不符合秩序。
Debate is not an order during a vote.
投票期间辩论不符合秩序。
Debate is not in order during a vote.
Mr. Kaine.
凯恩先生（Mr. Kaine）。
When I was sick, you visited me--
当我生病时，你来看我——
Debate is not allowed during a vote. The Senate will be in order.
投票期间禁止辩论。参议院将恢复秩序。
Mr. Kaine, no. Ms. Heitkamp.
凯恩先生，反对。海特坎普女士（Ms. Heitkamp）。
On behalf of the thousands of--
代表成千上万的——
Senator will suspend.
参议员请暂停。
--people who receive health care in my state and rural hospital--
——在我国和乡村医院接受医疗的人们——
Debate is not allowed.
禁止辩论。
--who know not how they're going to get her health care--
——不知道如果这在没有——
Senator will suspend.
参议员请暂停。
--if this passes without--
——通过的情况下如何获得医疗——
Clerk will begin a roll vote.
书记员将开始点名投票。
--without a replacement, I vote no.
——没有替代方案，我投票反对。
Senator will suspend.
参议员请暂停。
Ms. Heitkamp, no.
海特坎普女士，反对。
Is there any senator in the debate-- in the chamber that wishes to change their vote or vote? On this vote, the yeas are 51. The nays are 48. The concurrent resolution is agreed to.
辩论中——会议厅里有参议员希望改变他们的投票或进行投票吗？在这次投票中，赞成票51，反对票48。并发决议获得通过。
Act Six, Office Climate and Climate Office.
第六幕，办公室气候与气候办公室（Office Climate and Climate Office）。
So any new president gets to appoint over 4,000 people to various positions, but most of the people in those big buildings in Washington DC are not those 4,000 people. They are civil servants. Most of them stay in their jobs from one administration to the next, whoever's in power. Not all of them. Our producer David Kestenbaum spoke with a couple of civil servants in DC who were deciding whether to stick around.
所以任何新总统都能任命4000多人担任各种职位，但华盛顿特区那些大楼里的大多数人并非那4000人。他们是公务员。他们中的大多数人从一届政府到下一届政府都留在岗位上，无论谁当权。并非全部如此。我们的制作人戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）与华盛顿特区的几位公务员谈话，他们正在决定是否留下来。
Laura works at the Department of Energy, one of the agencies that seems like it might change dramatically under the new president. She asked us not to use her real name and to have an actor do her voice, even though she knows that's probably overkill.
劳拉（Laura）在能源部工作，这是看起来在新总统领导下可能会发生巨大变化的机构之一。她要求我们不要使用她的真名，并让演员替她配音，尽管她知道那可能有些过度了。
She says as a civil servant you're supposed to keep your politics and your job separate. Your job is to enact the policies of whoever's in power, Democrat or Republican. But the first day back after the election it was hard to keep her politics to herself.
她说作为一名公务员，你应该把政治和工作分开。你的工作是实施当权者的政策，无论是民主党还是共和党。但在选举后的第一天，她很难把政治倾向留给自己。
I've never cried at work before. When you cry, you can't hide the fact afterwards-- at least for me, my face gets really red. So I had a meeting or whatever. I just had to be like, sorry, I just had a moment. And then everybody else was like, yeah, we did, too. It's not just you.
我以前从没在工作中哭过。当你哭的时候，你事后掩盖不了——至少对我来说，我的脸会变得很红。所以我开了一个会什么的。我只能说，抱歉，我刚才情绪波动了一下。然后其他人说，是啊，我们也一样。不只是你。
I don't want to get into too much detail, but your job is climate change-related?
我不想讲太多细节，但你的工作是与气候变化相关的？
Yes.
是的。
How many people at DoE do you think are unconvinced that humans are causing global warming?
你认为能源部有多少人是不相信人类正在导致全球变暖的？
I don't know anyone at DoE who thinks that.
我不认识能源部里认为那样的任何人。
Do you think it's literally zero?
你认为真的是零吗？
Probably zero or close to zero.
大概是零或者接近零。
It looked like that number would rise by at least one. Rick Perry, Trump's pick to run the DoE, had written in his own book that he thought the science showing humans were contributing to climate change was a, quote, "contrived phony mess."
看起来那个数字至少会上升一个。特朗普挑选管理能源部的里克·佩里（Rick Perry），曾在自己的书中写道，他认为显示人类正在导致气候变化的科学是引用他的话，“虚构的假把戏”。
As you may have heard, Trump's team sent a list of questions to the DoE asking, among other things, the names of people who had attended UN climate change meetings. Democrats saw it as a kind of witch hunt.
正如你可能听说的，特朗普的团队向能源部发送了一份问题清单，询问的内容包括参加联合国气候变化会议的人员名单。民主党人将其视为一种猎巫行动。
Rick Perry now says his views on climate change have changed and that he didn't approve of the questionnaire. But after the election, Laura spent a lot of time wondering, should I stay in this job? What would it be like? What if the new bosses ask me to do something I just think is wrong?
里克·佩里现在说他对气候变化的看法已经改变，而且他没有批准那份调查问卷。但在选举后，劳拉花了很多时间思考，我应该留在这份工作中吗？会是什么样子？如果新老板让我做我仅仅认为是不对的事情怎么办？
Like what if there were some report or something and someone asked you to take out all the references to climate change?
比如如果有某种报告，而有人要求你删除所有关于气候变化的引用？
Well, we already did that.
嗯，我们已经那样做了。
You already did that?
你们已经那样做了？
Yeah, we have.
是的，我们已经做了。
Laura says she and a bunch of other people have been going through all their internal documents that describe ongoing projects and just scrubbing them, deleting the parts where it says, "and here's how this will help us combat climate change." Laura didn't want to talk specifics, but you could imagine a satellite for monitoring climate change and saying, think of it as a weather satellite instead. This renewable energy program? Now it's a jobs program.
劳拉说她和一群其他人一直在梳理他们所有描述正在进行项目的内部文件，并进行清洗，删除那些写着“这里是我们如何帮助应对气候变化”的部分。劳拉不想谈具体内容，但你可以想象一颗用于监测气候变化的卫星，并说，把它当作一颗气象卫星。这个可再生能源项目？现在它是一个就业项目。
Most federal projects have a bunch of reasons for their existence. Why draw attention to something by putting the words "climate change" in the description?
大多数联邦项目存在都有很多原因。为什么要通过在描述中放上“气候变化”这些词来引人注意呢？
Did it feel sad to take it out?
删除它感觉难过吗？
No.
不。
Because you thought, this is a way we can get by?
因为你心想，这是我们可以过关的一种方式？
Yeah, exactly. That was my thought. As long as it's getting done, it doesn't matter what we call it.
是的，正是如此。那是我的想法。只要事情完成了，叫什么名字并不重要。
Laura's entire time at the DoE has been under Obama. She's never been through a change of power before. That first day after the election, there was this big all-staff meeting at the DoE. That made her feel a little better-- not because it was emotional, but because it wasn't. It was professional, just like, here's what happens next.
劳拉在能源部的整个时间都是在奥巴马领导下。她以前从没经历过权力更迭。选举后的第一天，能源部举行了一次全体员工大会。那让她感觉好一点——不是因为它很情绪化，而是因为它很专业，就像，这是接下来会发生的事情。
I think what made it OK was it was very matter-of-fact. Like, the transition team is going to come in in the next few days. They didn't. They came in like several weeks later.
我认为让它没关系的原因是它非常公事公办。就像，过渡团队将在接下来的几天内进来。他们没有。他们是在几周后进来的。
When the transition team did arrive at DoE, Laura went on what felt like a kid detective mission to try to see the invaders. She knew they were on the fifth floor, so she went up there with a friend. They tried to play it cool, had to do a couple laps because they missed the room the first time. But there it was.
当过渡团队到达能源部时，劳拉进行了一次感觉像孩子般的侦探任务，试图看看这些入侵者。她知道他们在五楼，所以她和朋友一起上去了。她们试图保持冷静，因为第一次错过了房间，不得不绕了两圈。但它就在那里。
It literally said on the door, "transition team." And I elbowed my friend, and she was like, I saw it. It wasn't like something was hidden or something, but I felt very like, oh, wow. There it is.
门上真的写着“过渡团队”。我用胳膊肘碰了碰我的朋友，她说，我看到了。它不像有什么东西被隐藏起来，但我感觉非常，哦，哇。它就在那里。
Somehow seeing the office make you feel more reassured?
某种程度上看到办公室让你感到更放心？
Yeah, because the name was on the door. It's one of these things. It's like, well, they're not trying to hide anything. They're just there doing their job.
是的，因为名字写在门上。这是这些事情之一。就像，好吧，他们没试图隐瞒任何东西。他们只是在那里做他们的工作。
I talked to this other government worker who we'll call Karen. Karen's a relatively senior person. She served under a Democrat and a Republican. Karen says a bunch of younger coworkers have been coming into her office, closing the door, and saying, do you have a minute to talk? It's like she's become a therapist. Some of the people are trying to figure out what to do-- stay or leave. If you stay, at least you can try to steer things. Or you can fight.
我和另一位我们将称为凯伦（Karen）的政府工作人员谈过。凯伦是一位相对资深的人士。她在民主党人和共和党人手下任职。凯伦说一群年轻的同事一直在走进她的办公室，关上门，说，你有空谈谈吗？就像她变成了一名治疗师。有些人正在试图弄清楚该做什么——留下还是离开。如果你留下，至少你可以尝试引导事情。或者你可以战斗。
And by fight, I mean that in the most bureaucratic way possible. Government moves very slowly, which is a pain when you're trying to get things done. But if you're trying to stop something from happening, it can be used to your advantage.
通过战斗，我是指用尽可能官僚的方式。政府行动非常缓慢，当你试图把事情做完时这很痛苦。但如果你试图阻止事情发生，它可以成为你的优势。
Withholding information is one way you slow things down. The bureaucracy is large. There's a lot of paperwork, a lot of steps, and people that have been in government for a long time understand all those steps really well. So some of those tactics may be used to make things go a lot slower.
隐瞒信息是你放慢速度的一种方式。官僚机构很庞大。有很多文书工作，很多步骤，而在政府工作了很长时间的人非常了解所有这些步骤。所以其中一些战术可能会被用来让事情进行得慢得多。
One government worker told me he knew some people who were really good at this. It's like the dark arts of civil service. You can refer things to the general counsel for legal review. That takes time. You can also try to hide things.
一名政府工作人员告诉我，他认识一些非常擅长此道的人。这就像公务员制的暗黑艺术。你可以把事情提交给法律顾问进行法律审查。那需要时间。你也可以尝试隐瞒事情。
One relatively senior official who recently left government has been advising those who stayed behind to just lay low, keep any controversial stuff under the radar. Karen knows that trick.
一位最近刚离开政府的相对资深官员一直建议那些留下的人保持低调，把任何有争议的东西都置于雷达之下。凯伦知道那个诀窍。
It's not like you can come into the government and, with the click of a button, find everything you need to know on any topic we've worked on for the last 15 years.
不像你可以走进政府，按一下按钮，就能找到你在过去15年里所做工作的任何主题所需的一切信息。
So literally, there might be like programs or documents or things that are just so well hidden that they'd never find out about them?
所以字面上讲，可能有一些计划或文件或事情只是被藏得太好，以至于他们永远都不会发现它们？
You could say that.
你可以这样说。
Are people talking about doing that kind of stuff?
人们在讨论做那种事情吗？
I think people don't know yet how they will react because they are waiting to see if what they are predicting may happen does come to pass.
我认为人们还不知道他们将如何反应，因为他们正在等待看看他们所预测可能会发生的事情是否真的会发生。
But if it does?
但如果它真的发生了呢？
There are definitely some career civil servants that will not ever give in, and I think there are definitely some career civil servants that will toe the line. But I think the people that know how the system works have used these tactics within many administrations.
肯定有一些职业公务员永远不会屈服，而且我认为肯定有一些职业公务员会循规蹈矩。但我认为了解系统如何运作的人已经在许多届政府中使用了这些战术。
Sounds kind of wrong. It doesn't seem like the right thing to do.
听起来有点不对。那看起来不像是一件正确的事情。
I think when you've worked on something for a long time and you've devoted your entire career to it and you believe it is the right thing to do, people will do their jobs. But when they think that what they are doing is harmful to citizens or the country in the long run, I think they will stand up for what they believe in the bureaucratic ways that they can.
我认为当你长期从事某件事，并将你的整个职业生涯都致力于它，并且你相信它是正确的事情时，人们会做好他们的工作。但当他们认为他们正在做的事情在长远来看对公民或国家有害时，我认为他们会用他们能做到的官僚方式为他们所相信的事情挺身而出。
Karen is not going to be doing any of that. I imagine that's true of most people. They'll either do their jobs like good civil servants or they'll just leave. Karen is leaving. It didn't take her long to decide. She knew almost immediately, on election night.
凯伦不会做任何那种事情。我想对大多数人来说也是如此。他们要么会像优秀的公务员一样做好工作，要么就会离开。凯伦要离开了。她没花多长时间就决定了。她几乎立刻就知道了，在选举之夜。
I remember saying to a close friend, wow, I'll be departing from my job in January. And I'm a career public servant. [SOBS] I'm sorry.
我记得对一位亲密的朋友说，哇，我一月份就要离开我的工作了。我是职业公务员。（啜泣）抱歉。
Laura, at the Department of Energy, took longer to make up her mind. Senior people there-- Democrats-- were urging people to stay under Trump. Don't leave, they said. We need good people here. If you leave, you don't know who will replace you. And you don't know how bad it'll be. Maybe it'll be OK.
能源部的劳拉花了更长时间才拿定主意。那里的资深人士——民主党人——正在敦促人们在特朗普领导下留下。别走，他们说。我们需要这里有好的人。如果你走了，你不知道谁会取代你。而且你不知道会变得多糟。也许会没事的。
It was that questionnaire that sealed things for her, the one that made the news and asked for the names of people who had attended UN climate change talks. Laura wasn't in the office when the news broke. She heard about it by email from a friend in another part of government.
是那份调查问卷让她最终决定，那份上了新闻并要求提供参加联合国气候变化谈话人员名单的问卷。消息传出时劳拉不在办公室。她是通过政府另一部分的朋友发的电子邮件听说的。
Well, she was like, this doesn't look good, basically. And I was like, on the contrary, this is kind of funny.
嗯，她说，这看起来不妙，基本上。而我回答说，恰恰相反，这还有点滑稽。
It seemed like such an amateur move. The DoE, by the way, refused to provide any names.
这看起来像是非常业余的举动。顺便说一句，能源部拒绝提供任何名单。
That just seemed like a scare tactic to me, and I didn't want to reward that sort of brazen attempt to get people to leave the agency. I'm not leaving.
那对我来说只是恐吓手段，我不想奖励那种想让人们离开该机构的厚颜无耻的企图。我不会走的。
Are you thinking like, I can last four years?
你在想就像，我能坚持四年？
I think I can last four years.
我想我能坚持四年。
Could you last eight?
你能坚持八年吗？
I probably wouldn't stay for eight, no.
我可能不会留八年，不。
What are you doing for the inauguration?
你就职典礼那天打算做什么？
Probably hanging out with my friends in a bar.
大概和朋友们在酒吧里闲逛。
Watching it or avoiding it?
看它还是避免它？
Not watching it. I've already seen enough of him to last a lifetime.
不看。我已经见过他足够多了，足以维持一辈子了。
Well, she's going to be seeing more of him, as she knows.
嗯，正如她所知，她还会见到更多他。
We have these pictures hanging up in every office of the president, the vice president, the secretary of energy, and they're all going to change.
我们每间办公室里都挂着总统、副总统、能源部长的照片，而且它们都要换了。
You're going to have a picture of Donald Trump in your office?
你办公室里会挂一张唐纳德·特朗普的照片吗？
Yes. And Mike Pence and Rick Perry and whoever the undersecretary is.
是的。还有迈克·彭斯（Mike Pence）和里克·佩里，以及无论谁是副部长。
How do you feel about that?
你对此感觉如何？
I don't know. At least-- I mean, like-- that's like-- [SIGHS] it's just a reminder of the world we live in every day. I think you can bury your head a little bit and try to keep doing what you're doing, but there are people you answer to and that picture makes you remember who they are.
我不知道。至少——我的意思是，就像——那是就像——（叹气）这只是我们每天生活的世界的提醒。我想你可以把头稍微埋一下，尝试继续做你正在做的事，但有些人是你需要负责的，而那张照片让你记住他们是谁。
We looked into it. The portraits of Obama and his officials were scheduled to be removed on Friday at noon, the exact time Donald Trump took the oath of office. We were told the pictures would be disposed of respectfully. In my mind, there's a big dumpster somewhere with all of the photos in it, like an actual dustbin of history. The frames do get saved and reused for the new portraits. They're going to be going up in the next few weeks.
我们查了一下。奥巴马及其官员的肖像原定于周五中午，即唐纳德·特朗普宣誓就职的准确时间被移除。我们被告知这些照片会被尊重地处理。在我看来，某个地方有一个巨大的垃圾箱，里面装着所有的照片，就像一个真正的历史尘埃桶。框子会被保存并重新利用用于新的肖像。它们将在接下来的几周内挂上去。
David Kestenbaum is one of the producers of our program. The actor who performed Laura's quotes is Jen Davis.
戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的制作人之一。扮演劳拉引言的演员是简·戴维斯（Jen Davis）。
Our program was produced today by David Kestenbaum. Our production staff includes Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvas, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu. Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Music help today from Damian Graef.
我们今天的节目由戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆制作。我们的制作人员包括苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、佐伊·蔡斯、达纳·奇瓦斯（Dana Chivvas）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming）、凯伦·达芬（Karen Duffin）、伊曼纽尔·佐齐（Emmanuel Dzotsi）、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和戴安·吴（Diane Wu）。今天的研究帮助来自克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）和米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）。今天的音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damian Graef）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our show's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. He does not understand why the president's motorcade has to cause so much traffic whenever he's driving around New York heading to Trump Tower.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他不明白为什么总统的车队无论何时在纽约开车前往特朗普大厦时都要造成那么严重的交通拥堵。
Like, he has legs.
就像，他有腿。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。